[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CROWD CHEERING AND CLAPPING]
DIANE GREENE: Thank you,
so much, and welcome.
This is just an
incredibly exciting event.
Everybody at Google Cloud
is so proud of the customers
that we have here today.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Our
customers and partners
will see many ways to
leverage all of Google.
Be it Google Maps, Android,
YouTube, our devices ecosystem.
SPEAKER 1: Google.
Let me talk to eBay.
[CHIME]
SPEAKER 2 (ON GOOGLE HOME): Hi.
I'm eBay.
You can ask me what
something is worth.
URS HOLZLE: We put
a security chip
to serve as the basis of trust
for that machine's identity.
In fact, it's so small
that I'm actually
wearing one on my earring here.
[CLAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 3: This is why
the next step for AI
must be democratization.
We at Google Cloud are
making the tools available,
but it's up to you
to put them to use.
SPEAKER 4: Jamboard is a
whiteboard in the Cloud,
in the meeting room, and
beyond your meeting room.
You start thinking,
communicating,
and working with your team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 5: The core
promise to developers
still remains the same.
Bring your code, and Google
will handle everything else.
SPEAKER 6: What really
inspires us and motivates
us is thinking about what
all of us can build together.
SPEAKER 7: Just get
to the Cloud now.
There's no time
to waste any more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]